they're one of the few teams that looks
to attack inside on switches as they did
there curry
unable to hit his first try
stephen curry long three on its way
we're on the three-pointer watch with
curry green offensive board and the
layup made the comment the other day
that they have the best center combo
in the nba i think there's some other
teams that can challenge
but it has been a very effective
combination
for monty williams
wide open lane mcgee and ayden taking
advantage not part of it right now in
this window of time after the steve kerr
timeout both teams go small curry no and
johnson with a rebound at least as an
option
really hurts them
curry takes the contact he'll whistle
anderson
cannot put it back another great ball
movement there
against the four-man zen
curry goes all the way in misses the
bunny
ain't contesting and the warriors get it
back well great ball movement there
against the four man
curry goes all the way in misses the
bunny
contesting
and the warriors get it back
and otto porter
have carried the water and now curry
missed it
[Applause]
ernie kenny shaq and charles coming up
american express halftime report
second of our double header saw the next
beat the knicks earlier is a block by
aidan
he was out deep 30 foot range for curry
to help early ayton went to the open
spot hayden's first points of the second
quarter curry goes right by it this time
by bridges
thank you allen good stuff stephen curry
with eight points it was really
jordan poole and otto porter
who
went off in that first half combining
for 30 points and now curry misses his
first try
look her out the rest of the game left
hamstring injury
first points for mackel bridges curry
cannot answer sun's trying to keep the
run go you got to make it as tough on
him as you can and then you've got to
hope they missed it he's got 11. here's
a long three on its way and another air
ball that's a second
with 20 now
[Applause]
in the first half especially the second
quarter there were 15 combined perry's
got eight
[Applause]
gives it up and nice play by bridges
that
long reach
seven point game
now it's called on curry and it is aidan
with the deflection shaman with a steal